you open your show like this show you
open with a monologue yeah I saw your
opening monologue tonight it was who's
alright I'm one of the best monologue
lists of all time so Wow well you
certainly know what you're talking about
so you you you you think your monologues
better than my monologue yeah I'm
positive
oh really yeah lunch you put your money
with you okay look I Jos on this crowd
yeah I would love to you guys ready for
some monologue action well he got here I
so they got this actor out now named Jon
Hamm have you heard of him what's next
an actor named Jon roast beef they got
this singer - now Yoko Ono have you
heard of her call me when there's a Yoko
dose so they're having the Olympics in
Rio de Janeiro that's exciting
what's next the Olympics in Robert De
Niro walked in here
[Applause]
you're very good it's all your material
one of the pros now one of your things
that you strive for it's gonna leave
that dead guy
you